we were talking about the Muller report
earlier and I actually we joke around
about it but I really have I do a pond
this stuff I know my facts and there's
one more point about I want to make
about it that no one's made and because
I have an interesting theory do you want
to hear this Andy yeah sure okay okay
I'll see here's my point I think this
whole thing if you really want to get
into the nuts and bolts of it
goes back to July 2016 at a meeting
about a new Trump Tower in Moscow if you
look at it that's the same month the FBI
discovered Russia was attempting to hack
the election which if he's lined them up
side-by-side you can see that actually
this was oh my god I had to get out of
there
like we need yet another person talking
about the Muller investigation I mean
just Conan really think he's gonna solve
this thing all by himself give it a rest
gumshoe alright I better get back we'll
just find out then what Donald Trump jr.
knew and what he said at that particular
moment you just look at the email time
stamps and then you're gonna have
cracked the whole thing oh yeah
definitely
yeah you know speaking of Moscow that
reminds me of a crazy dream I had the
other night I was trapped in Siberia I'm
hunting down a microchip stuck inside
this robot dog and the dog goes out into
the tundra come on in the fastest way to
put an audience to sleep is by telling
about a dream you had
these people deserve better doesn't any
have a therapist he can bore with this
idiotic stuff oh he has two therapists
actually
oh yeah sorry Andy I didn't know you
could hear that
oh listen I don't care I hate his dream
talk to ya I had no idea you felt that
way oh oh sure he's been insufferable
for years yeah hey well this guy here
thinks he's Woodward and Bernstein what
a bore this guy thinks he's Carl Jung I
don't know who's got it worse between us
it's a toss-up we both suck I know who's
got it worse me I'm the one who left the
film this snoozefest
Tony the camera man's right Conan listen
let's go grab a drink Andy's dreams are
long he'll be talking for 20 minutes
great idea let's ditch these pouring
losers can I come I love to drink me too
you